here are this week's top movies Jumanji  for teenagers magically enter a game and  become their chosen adult avatars in  Jumanji welcome to the jungle  the Bellas reunite one last time for an  overseas tour and face their biggest  challenge yet in pitch perfect 3 let  Sokka finish this bye bye Bella's you  want my advice  leisure lands where you want to be  little in the social satire downsizing a  man decides to shriek himself so he can  lead a better life the world is filled  with things to see see what's hot in  theatres with this week's fantasy  patient so what's your weekend ticket  going to be let us know by commenting  see you next time on weekend ticket